invention adapteur tremblé dans son nez
sur wii bon les nouvelles étaient bonnes
quand même oui les nouvelles étaient
bonnes une nouvelle épée bonne parce que
le plan est raisonnable et puis que la
situation et puis l'egypte nous permet
de faire seul et qu'on file
bon on va regarder ensemble et date le
28 mai sur une date
la première date importante devant nous
fin du couvre-feu
c'est terminé j'ai pas de 21h30 vient de
se terminer
terrasses des restaurants on les ouvre
huit personnes à l'extérieur on pourra
faire des petits rassemblements
familiaux 1 et spectacles sports jusqu'à
2500 personnes le 2500 c'est dans des
endroits où on a des places désigné on
pense au centre bell par exemple le
canadien traverse les premiers matchs
avec les livres on pourrait ouvrir le
centre bell
bonchamp ferions bien pas de problème
avec ça jusqu'ici non dans la mesure où
ils ont bien précisé que ce serait de
perception de 250 personnes donc on
essaie encore de limiter les les
instruments et les possibilités de
contamination alors ça me semble
résonnèrent dans les très grands espaces
bon on juin on ajoute les terrasses des
bars partout au québec pourront ouvrir
on est les sports loisirs extérieurs on
pense au soccer etc
vingt-cinq personnes soit celle ci est
la continuation logique quoi
oui puisqu'ils et experte avec les peaux
problématique parce qu'on sait qu'à
l'extérieur lui le degré de contagion
est beaucoup moindre
donc ça nous permet ces étapes le nous
permettent d'accumuler encore plus de
monde accéder pendant ce temps là pour
se rendre aux prochaines étapes et de
manière générale parallèle à cette sauce
et des dates qui s'applique partout sur
le territoire québécois
mais on dit si la fin mais la plupart
des régions a dit monsieur legault
seront en zone orange donc les jam vont
rouvrir etc
on est rendu là pensez-vous dr tremblay
oui je pense qu'on est rendu là parce
que on voit le nombre de cas baisser de
façon systématique depuis déjà plusieurs
semaines dans
un élément important c'était que la
tendance se maintienne donc ce ne soit
pas juste quelque chose d'une semaine
les hospitalisations sont en baisse les
décès sont malheureusement toujours
autour de l'ip du copain parle par jour
mais quand même la situation
l'épidémiologie qu ils montrent que
moins de transmission communautaire et
on le voit en eux mêmes
on est sous le seuil des 500
hospitalisations à 484 à pareille date
l'an dernier on était à 1438 je crois là
où en tout cas autour de ça donc c'est
un autre monde
donc c'est dire docteur tremblay vous
allez dire sur une évidence mais c'est
dire que la vaccination
ça fonctionne oui puis on est tellement
chanceux d'avoir on n'est pas chanceux
d'avoir une pandémie mais on est
chanceux d'avoir mieux des vaccins qui
ont développé très rapidement et qu'ils
ont une efficacité de 95 pour ça c'est
c'est le fruit de la science du travail
de beaucoup de gens mais ça aurait pu me
posait alors ayant c'est utile à un mail
c'est ce qui nous permet de sortir de la
polémique
bon parlons de la vaccination parce que
je garde la dernière date pour après le
monsieur legault nous parle de faim ou
mais a juste avant voyant le seuil
actuel on est à 60,3 de la population
adulte dont 18 ans et plus et deuxièmes
noces à peu près pas comment sont à 3 7%
l'objectif pour la fin
d'où ce et les 12 ans et plus donc ce
n'est pas la population doit on agrandit
encore le cercle d'arriver donc à 75%
première et deuxième dose de toute la
population de 12 ans et plus est
possible d'opter entre amis oui c'est
tout à fait possible pour commencer les
12 17 ans ça va être très facile à faire
dans le cadre du milieu scolaire donc on
voit facilement
on y rendu à 60% et ce qu'on disait
qu'avec les rendez vous
qui sont pris déjà on estime qu'on voit
à peine de tout objectif de 75% des les
halles du payant leurs premières doses
en début d'été alors apprécier la
deuxième dose c'est plus on note d'accès
plus on peut les devancer par l'idée de
les espaces aux quatre mois c'était
parce qu'on a manqué d'accès et donc on
voulait vacciner le plus de monde
possible
regardez les vaccins qu'on avait pour
d'accès le plus de monde possible
mais dans la mesure où on a tous nos
vaccins quitte les gens ont vu leurs
premières doses on pouvait reprocher la
deuxième dose donc on va pouvoir
vacciner
j'ouvre une parenthèse sur la deuxième
dose on soit encore énormément de
questions des gens qui ont reçu l'astra
zeneca étonnement est ce que je devrais
prendre ou pas comme deuxième dose
d'astrazeneca
en fait est ce qu'on se rend compte que
les maladies rares qui sont arrivés avec
astrazeneca c'est trop beau c'est vers
là sont arrivés dans l'immense majorité
des cas à la première dose autrement dit
quand libre lance une fois qu'ils ont
pas fait de réaction et ils vont pas en
faire à l'aide à la deuxième dose donc
le risque était des jeunes minimes l'est
encore plus c'est la deuxième dose alors
moi je m'en priverai pas de le recevoir
par finition peut la voir la phrase
indication n'a pas eu de problème il n'y
a pas de problème parce que j'adore chez
le risque est insignifiant par ailleurs
si quelqu'un veut vraiment pas là sera
zeneca est ce qu'on sait maintenant si
on peut prendre deux jeunes dont pfizer
sont à lui la troisième est que les
données sont pas encore publiés mais on
pense qu'il y aura pas de problème vis
de toute façon pas parce qu'il n'y aura
pas assez d'astrazeneca pour vacciner
les deuxième dose à leurs enfants ce qui
théoriquement d'un point de vue
scientifique il faut vraiment de raison
de penser que ça ne fonctionnerait pas
mais si je prends mes temps j'ai eu la
cerise et les cas je prends le finder
comme deuxième dose est ce que je
devrais prendre une troisième dont
pfizer qui serait ma deuxième dose files
un nom fort probablement parce que
l'idée la deuxième dos et deux heureux
aussi l'effet de la première d'autres
occasions de monter des antilles car
quand on pense que la première dose de
vaccin
puis le 2
vaccin il réveille les cellules de
mémoire qui ont été développées lors de
la première dose pour qu'elles mêmes
produisent les anticorps donc il répond
nécessité d'avoir une troisième dose à
moins que faire avec marianne mais ce
serait ok donc même si on change de
famille de vaccins on n'aura pas besoin
d'ajouter le deuxième sur la deuxième le
masque monsieur legault a d'ici la fin
d'où les gens on est arrivé au seuil de
75% de la population de 12 ans et plus
au québec ce sont les deux vaccins on
pourra enlever le masque vous êtes
d'accord avec ça ben oui dans la mesure
où quand les gens sur deux doses de
vaccin
ils sont quand même protégé a pu 95% et
si on est de plus en plus de gens se
regrouper avec deux doses de vaccin
les gens sont protégés ils ont leurs
propres besoins de masques entre eux
ceci dit voyons où on en est rendu à la
fin ou et puis sinon atteindre 75%
voyons quelle est la transcription comme
nos pères qui persistent et puis faut
toujours avoir en tête les variantes
possibles qui pourraient émerger
d'ailleurs et puis venir ou l'oubli un
peu alors juste avant de dire à la fin
du mois d'août définir plupart des
milers jeune garde reine dit réserve
ouais on se garde un petit trésor mais
depuis qu'on se parle de ça va faire
quoi un an et demi qu'on se parle
docteur tremblay celles entrevues la
plus agréable
c'est toujours agréable comprennent ce
que je veux dire
ces entrevues la plus lumineuse oui
c'est la plus lumineuse parce qu'on a on
a vraiment raison de croire que on se
sort de la pandémie et ce grâce à la
participation et la contribution de tous
les québécois et québécoises parce que
c'est pas juste le vaccin si tous les
efforts qui ont été mis chelem raison le
confinement et puis tout ça tout ça
contribué à ce qu'ont pu s en servir
l'estrie se sauver c'est la vaccination
puis d'ailleurs on sentait chez monsieur
legault cette fierté lors aujourd'hui
des québécois de cet effort collectif
qui a été fait l'ambiance est quand même
boulot c'est dur mais il ya quelque
chose de bon là tu as vraiment très beau
c'est des gestes de solidarité puis les
gens le font pas juste pour eux mêmes
ils le font pour les autres ils le font
pour qu'on s'en sorte collectivement de
la pandémie
je vous garde falloir garder en tête
cette solidarité l'autre quand on va
parler de la pandémie à l'échelle
internationale parce que c'est pas parce
qu'ici au québec ont atteint 75 % 10
minutes et que la pandémie fini qu'on
est pauvre menacé de l'extérieur qu'il
n'y a pas d'autres peuples qui souffrent
alors faut garder ça en tête aussi tout
à fait docteur tremblay merci beaucoup
encore une fois merci et jean plaisait
au revoir